would be able to upload our mind in a
computer
in a way where we might even transcend
the constraints of our bodies so copy
our mind into a computer and leave the
body behind
let me describe one thing I've already
done with my father
that's a great story
so we we created technology this is
public came out I think six years ago
where you could ask any question and the
release product which I think is still
on the market uh it would read 200 000
books
and then and then find the one sentence
in 200 000 books that best answered your
question
uh and it's actually quite interesting
you can ask all kinds of questions and
you get the best answer in 200 000 books
but I was also able to to take it and uh
not go through 200 000 books but go
through a book that I
put together which is basically
everything my father had written
so everything he had written had
gathered
and we created a book
everything that Frederick Israel had
written now
I didn't think this actually would work
that well because
uh stuff he'd written was
stuff about how to lay out I mean he did
uh corrected Coral groups and music
groups and he would be laying out how
the people should where they should sit
and
as how to fund this and all kinds of
things that really weren't didn't seem
that interesting
um
and yeah when you ask a question it
would go through it and it would
actually give you a very good answer
so I said well you know who's the most
interesting composer and he said well
definitely Brahms he would go on about
how problems was fabulous and talk about
the importance of music education and
so you could have a essentially a uh so
you can have an answer a conversation
can I have a conversation with them
which is actually more interesting than
talking to him because if you talk to
him he'd be concerned about how they're
going to lay out this property to give a
choral group he'd be concerned about the
day-to-day versus the big questions
exactly yeah
and you did ask about the meaning of
life and he answered love yeah
do you miss him
yes I do
um
yeah you get used to missing somebody
after 52 years
and I didn't really have
intelligent conversations with them
until later in life
um
in the last few years he was sick which
meant he was home a lot and I was
actually able to talk to him about
different things like music and other
things and
uh so I missed that very much what did
you learn about life from your father
foreign
part of him is is with you now
he was devoted to music
and when he would create something to
music it put him in a different world
uh otherwise he was very shy
um
and if people got together he tended not
to interact with people just because it
was China's
but when he created music that
he was like a different person
do you have that in you that yeah kind
of light that shines I mean I I got
involved
with technology it's like age five
and you fell in love with it in the same
way he did with music yeah
I remember
this actually happened with my
grandmother
she had a manual typewriter
and she wrote a book when life is not
enough it's actually a good title for a
book I might write but and it was about
a school she had created
well actually her mother created it
so my mother's mother's mother created
the school in 1868 and it was the first
school in Europe that provided higher
education for girls it went through 14th
grade
if you were a girl and you were lucky
enough to get an education at all it
would go through like ninth grade and
many people didn't have any education as
a girl
uh this went through 14th grade
um her mother created it she took it
over
and then and the book was about
uh the history of the school and her
involvement with it
um when she presented to me I was not so
interested in the story of the book of
the school
but I was totally amazed with this
manual typewriter
I mean here is something you could put a
blank piece of paper into and you could
turn it into something that looked like
it came from a book
and you can actually type on it and it
looked like it came from a book it was
just amazing to me
and I could see actually how it worked
and I was also interested in magic
um
but in Magic if somebody actually knows
how it works the magic goes away
the magic doesn't stay there if you
actually understand how it works
but he was technology I didn't have that
word when I was five or six and the
magic was still there for you the magic
was still there even if you knew how it
worked yeah
so I became totally interested in this
and then went around collected little
pieces of mechanical objects from
bicycles from broken radios or go
through the neighborhood
this was an ERA where you would allow
five or six-year-olds who like roam
through the neighborhood and do this we
don't do that anymore but they didn't
know how to put them together and I said
if I could just figure out how to put
these things together I could solve any
problem
and I actually remember talking to these
very old girls I think they were 10.
um
and telling them I if I could just
figure this out we could fly we could do
anything and they said well you have
quite an imagination
um and then I can then when I was in
third grade
so it's like eight
created like a virtual reality theater
where people could come on stage and
they could move their arms
and all of it was controlled through one
control box it was also with mechanical
technology
and it was a big hit in my third grade
class
and then I went on to do things in
junior high school science fairs and and
high school science fairs where I won
the Westinghouse science Talent search
so I mean I became committed to
technology when I was
five or six years old